welcome everyone
uh for another episode of dc thursday
i'm pete soderling i'm the founder of
data council
and the data community fund and we're
excited that you join us
almost every thursday as we chat with a
leader
of a company open source project
or tool in the data ecosystem and today
we're very fortunate to have
boris yavez who
is from census and boris i think i just
um said your name wrong even though we
discussed it so it's
jabez boris javez
we aim to please we aim to please here
at dc thursday so
um even if it means uh repeating things
on the air
and showing a healthy dose of humility
that's something that
um is in line with our values so um
boris
thank you for joining us and um and for
your
your patience um with the name uh we're
really really happy that you're here
today to talk to us i'm very happy to be
here man pete it's great
great to do this so um boris you have a
pretty interesting
background um you started a company
before
it was meldium that you told to log me
in
and before that you were a senior pm at
microsoft
so i want to keep those things in
context because usually
as we traverse your experience and your
career
um we find that these things sort of
stack up
um to pointing you to where you're at
today and so
i like to i like to keep in mind um but
i i wanted to start off and ask you
you went through y combinator and so i
was curious to hear a little bit
more about that experience um obviously
it was a company
before census i believe it was meldium
that you took through like yc
is that right that's right awesome tell
us a little bit about that experience
and what it was like as an engineer
um you know going to the startup
accelerator like that yeah
yeah it was um it almost feels like a
different time
uh uh in the valley this was in uh 2013
y combinator of people who for people
who know is now a much larger
organization
uh i think they you know they there are
roughly like 400 companies i think that
go through yc a year now maybe 500
and we were a batch of 40 companies
going through yc at the time
uh it's overall it's a really
it's a really amazing experience it is
my short answer
uh for a couple of reasons one is as
with any any great uh kind of
uh uh organization you're around a great
cohort of people
and so it's not just that paul graham
was an amazing kind of
uh mentor for startups and could really
help you
think through your ideas and how to
build something kind of big
but you're also around unbelievably
ambitious founders
so i think the two things i got
from yc is the first which is in the
name right
y combinator is it's not going to make
your company it's not going to
it's not going to incubate it right as
the to use that term it really is about
accelerating you
on the path that you're on and they do
that mostly by helping you focus on the
things that matter right which is
mostly the short answer on this is like
focusing on growth
and uh focusing on the you know the
derivative derivative rather than
everything else
and just just and that that's a very
very useful thing when you're a
first-time founder because
it's easy to either not know what to do
at all
or to try to adopt all the things you
were doing as a as an employee of a
company
where you know how to build software but
but you're not you know you don't
realize like
what changes you have to make when
you're out in the open building
like you have to make a lot more
sacrifices and focus on a lot less
things
because you don't have the you know the
bandwidth to do everything
and then the other thing that i got from
y combinator that i think is
under-appreciated and maybe it doesn't
get talked about as much
it's really like an ambition boost uh
paul graham
especially was really good at taking any
idea that people had
and seeing it in a bigger way than any
of the founders did
so so you know uh meldium was a uh
identity management product right it was
a single sign-on product so for people
who know octa it was kind of like that
but much more focused on
passwords and and kind of helping uh
teams and companies
use sas products seamlessly where so you
didn't have to deal with password
management as a team
and you can think of it as nowadays for
people would be like some opportunity
like a crosstown one password and octa
think of like the the marriage of those
two things and it was a little bit ahead
of its time
and the you know
we had some ambitions that we thought
this was a great idea and needed to be
existed in the world but he took it to
like oh
you know you will have every password in
the universe right like this is amazing
like you
you could and so he helps you think of
the maximal version of your of your
product your company and that's
very very empowering right because you
have to be able to kind of
struggle through really tough times uh
as you build your company
so i think those are those are probably
the things i remember the most about yc
and then
like i said your cohort is is just
excellent i've made you know you make
amazing friends who are all
you know just brilliant and ambitious
um and you you've spoken before i think
about how
your foray into the auth identity
world and that part of infrastructure um
somehow prepared you for
um for the what you call the flip side
of the point and thinking about
the data world um what's what's the
relationship between the two
and how did you get from one to the
other yeah yeah
i mean i think a lot of founders
start with you know something they've
some pain they've experienced themselves
right so
if i could yeah the the back story here
would be the best way to think about it
is when we started our first company we
were
we wanted to use all the sas products
that were coming out
back in 2012. you know whether that's
google apps github
nowadays there's thousands right but it
was new it was like you really wanted to
be able to use these great
apps and there was this chaos that came
out of that because you had to manage
employee passwords in every single
system it was really frustrating
and so we built a seamless tool to be
able to kind of manage a team
log in seamlessly and and be able to you
know kind of have all the control
and the comfort of you know not having
to worry about
access management but as a user the
upside is i could use
any piece of software i wanted to and i
was not limited
by the set of software that my it team
gave me
and the the analogy i give for this
is when sas emerged there were two
pieces
of the kind of computer operating system
that were
forgotten so when you have a computer
and you
install apps right going back into the
80s and 90s
you would log into your computer and not
into photoshop
right and you would have a file system
on your computer and not in photoshop
and those two things were missing in sas
and so meldium
was an attempt to create a central
federated
authentication system so that every sas
app could avoid having to build that
and i would say that you know octa is
evidence of kind of how that
grew into a massive uh a massive market
in massive business
and census when i say the flip side of
the coin is trying to do the same thing
for
the rest of your data instead of
employee identity it's like your
customer data
which in a way is yours as a company
but you want it federated to every
possible sas app that you're using
and in order to use the maximum number
of sas apps in the world you want to
have a great
federation system for that and so that's
how census was born as like you know the
flip side of that coin and
so a lot of a lot of what i learned
building meldium
you know kind of applies here even
though authentication
and it are very different from data and
and
you know data tooling so there's
this notion of federation plus sort of
consumption
by third-party systems that that seems
to be a guiding principle for you
yeah yeah that was very much at the root
yeah that was very much at the root of
of the idea well
i think i think it's going to be an
interesting conversation because you're
playing
really in um what many consider to be
a new category of data the data
ecosystem
and essentially what we're talking about
today um
you know through our chat is this area
to the right of of the data warehouse
and it seems to me that you know when i
met you and
sean your co-founder like early on
several years ago
um and sean was telling me about this
tool
that was piping data you know from a
database or a data warehouse like back
into business tools for sales people
um it wasn't even necessarily obvious
that you
necessarily were a piece of data
infrastructure
per se or weren't necessarily thinking
of it like that
um i kind of want to get your thoughts
on that because it seems like it wasn't
obvious even to to you and the team
um that that this was essentially it
could be a data it
could become a data infrastructure
company like how are you thinking of it
at the time that's
very true and yeah you have a you have
the unique uh
uh advantage of having met census very
early in its life so census
started in 2018 uh and
the core first version of the product is
still
the product which was this bridge
between the data warehouse and
this application salesforce being the
very first one unsurprisingly
and you're absolutely right that
when we started when we built that and
we were
out looking for our first couple
customers we
knew this was useful because we had felt
this pain uh in particular actually
after uh after we sold meldium
to this larger kind of public company
called log me in the the sales and
marketing teams were completely
separated and disjointed from
our team and we had all this amazing
product data so so we knew there was a
disconnect there like we needed a bridge
built
the question is who who who's going to
drive that right who's going to install
it and manage it
and uh the
even though it's a it's a physically
it's connected to the data warehouse it
wasn't
obvious back in 2018 that
data organizations would want to touch
this
right because historically this was not
in their purview right
historically i think a data team owns
the data infrastructure
but not these business application
scenarios and so
the some of the early users of census
were on the edge
of what you would call the data team and
they were basically business operations
teams
and if you were to zoom in though right
you would realize like
these these are effectively at the very
least analysts
they just don't use the data title uh
and the further we kind of
got users and fans back in 2018 and 2019
the more it became plausible and then
obvious
basically one at a time right plausible
then possible than you know obvious
that data teams were the
the best custodians of this because it
sits
on the data infrastructure and it
actually increases the
it magnifies the output of a data team
which is a very kind of attractive thing
well um on on that note um you know why
don't you
tell us just so that the audience um
have the benefit of understanding where
you're coming from
um why don't you tell us about what
census does because i think
there's a lot to unpack in you know what
you said and i don't want
our common sort of shared um you know
knowledge
or previous conversations um to leave
everyone else in the dust but
i think what you mentioned was something
to the effect that
previously teams sort of thought that
that data stopped at the dashboard
right like the dashboard was the last
place that data was consumed
and it sounds to me like you're talking
about something that might go
above and beyond that and tell us more
yeah
so so yeah let's let's let's explain uh
what
census the product is for the the people
who have no context like you
um census is
a automated data pipeline product right
it connects to a data warehouse
and syndicates data out it publishes
data from a data warehouse
into all the interesting business
applications that companies use
whether that's sales tools right
salesforce hubspot etc
support tools like zendesk intercom or
finance tools like netsuite so it's
about taking
data and models and insights that live
in a data warehouse and
pushing them out seamlessly on a regular
cadence so that the state
that lives in your warehouse can be
syndicated right it can be federated
out to applications so that's what
census does uh
and it was born like i said as this
bridge between hey i want to get
product data product analytics
especially into my sales tool
so that my sales team can target the
right leads or
better understand the users or drive
upsells etc that was
one of the very earliest of scenarios
and so
implied in that right is the
the use cases that census enables which
were
completely new at the time and you know
like i said in 2018 really
i don't think almost any data team was
doing anything like this
was going far beyond a dashboard into
action that sales at first like i said
sales teams but eventually you know
marketing finance etc
uh uh are powered by census and
and what i mean by action is you're not
showing them
information in a dashboard you're not
even embedding analytics which was
kind of well trodden ground i think by
tableau and tools like looker
already back then we were saying what if
you could
generate information in a third-party
system and potentially
mean that you're changing the behavior
of the end user so
i'll give you the simplest of examples
a lot of our customers right are really
kind of product led
uh companies they have lots of freemium
users they have lots of users period
and you really can't you know it's a lot
of work to sift
through that to figure out who a sales
person should actually engage with
it's kind of we kind of understand that
and there's a lot of amazing analytics
to understand who high value users are
you can put that on a dashboard but that
doesn't change the fact that a sales
person has to wake up in the morning and
decide who am i calling today
who am i talking to and
our customers use census to take
uh the the scoring and insights they
have on the users that are most likely
to convert
and send that directly into the crm as
leads or objects or contacts or accounts
such that you know the sales person will
wake up and their past list will already
be generated
and they can just do their work they can
just start making the calls and
and that's very different than in terms
of a relationship between a data team
and
their stakeholders of a dashboard right
because now
it's actually my work list it's just
generated from this
yeah that's fascinating um so in that
use case
um does census have somewhat of a brain
to be able to do the lead scoring
as well or to what to what extent does
the census have
business logic versus you know the
business logic sort of remaining
in the in the end tool um the crm
in this example yeah so
i would say you see peop you know
there's logic can live on either end of
the let's call it the bridge right so
since this is this bridge between the
warehouse and let's say your sales tool
some folks choose to bring kind of
well-modeled data into the crm and let
the crm decide
so you might say i want to bring in
really precise information about
how many users are in in this
organization in this company right so we
have
take figma right they have millions and
millions of users all these
organizations
you could do hey let's sync exactly how
many active users there are in every
account
and then you can have a rule in
salesforce that says if an account has
more than x
active users they should be routed to
this sales team where there's a round
robin you know assignment and
uh they will they will take the work
right so there's definitely companies
that do it that way
and then there are companies where the
the
i'll just say that the programming model
for this in salesforce
can be frustrating for some people and
sql and the warehouse is an amazing
execution environment so a lot of our
customers
actually kind of do it the other way
where they'll create those rules
as just another layer in their modeling
stack
that can live in census right like we we
can execute arbitrary
kind of anything your warehouse can
execute we can execute through census
and they'll create those rules there and
by rules i just mean
yet another you know sql transform and
then just send that
across the wire so some people treat
their destination apps
as slightly dumber terminals over the
data that
is in the warehouse and some of them you
know maintain kind of a lot of logic in
the end system
but they still want the correct source
data to come and the only
true arbiter of correct information is
the data team in the data warehouse
and like going back to the early days um
what what were some of the
the validation points that you
discovered when you spoke to early
customers like
how did you know that you were onto
something again back in 2018
like when it wasn't as clear perhaps as
this today yeah
yeah so yeah so i think the
like i said a lot of startups i think
are born this way we we built our first
version because we knew we had
experienced this pain right so
we uh and we felt well okay what kind of
companies would resemble meldium right
meldium was product led
freemium uh and had
had had suddenly been assigned you know
external sales and marketing so
so i was like who who might look like
that and
we we're very much builders right so
instead of just
some people will go out with a with a
with a powerpoint and walk around town
and and see who would be who would bite
and i i really respect that
uh we you know kind of just spent a
month building kind of our first version
of this thing
and we we kind of took that around to
some friends where we said well
you theoretically should look like this
but it was much more of an exploration
and
um i think the first aha moment was
in 2018 figma was
just about to go on a tear and and they
had just hired their initial sales team
right they had this massive adoption
already like self-service
but now they wanted to expand and one of
the things that i've noticed in
in in a lot of companies and this was
like i said the first aha moment is
no one wants to end up in kind of what i
call the evernote trap where you have
this a great freemium product and
they're self-service but you never
figure out like the
scaling revenue all the way up to
enterprise
and figma knew this and so they were
starting around their series b and
investing in
enterprise sales but they wanted to
create that funnel that goes from free
to pro to enterprise and they
they they had when they saw what we had
built they said this is correct
this is this is the mindset that we have
because
salesforce is at the end of this and and
the data and our data warehouse that
they were using redshift was where all
their interesting product data lived and
they knew
they wanted this to be powered off of
that flow because
most people were self-service so the
last thing you want to do is call people
who have like just paid with their
credit card like why would you want to
do that
so it was really that was that first
confirmation that we were
doing the right thing but of course one
customer is you know that's enough to
to kind of tide you over for a bit and
then we just
kind of the first 10 customers that we
got were
were very much in this vein and
uh they just kind of increasingly
confirmed that hey there's a need here
and then i started noticing kind of
changes in behavior that
really kind of told me things were going
to get
interesting so i just wanted to clarify
one thing you said because you mentioned
that
it sounded like you wanted to sell to
other customers that had the mentality
that meldium had
meaning yeah product led bottoms up um
and that was just because that was your
view of the world as a founder
like you believed in that court of
market motion and you wanted to build
some tool
for other companies who believed in a
similar bottoms up motion
is that fair yeah i i might even go
slightly
stronger in that the the premise
look if you let's rewind right every
company
since the dawn of you know companies has
had customers
and some form of customer data whether
that's a physical rolodex somewhere you
know in a sales person's hand
or cue cards or whatever uh um or a
database
and salesforce is the
the you know standard for the last 10
plus years right like it's the database
that
not that it's 100 of the market but a
huge percentage of companies
have their customer data there and the
reason they do is that
it's a great tool for for for tracking
the work of sales people
but my premise which again was informed
from meldium is
if software is the thing that you're
selling and
growth is driven from the software i.e
bottom up product led which seems
obvious to people i think in in the
valley but
not necessary but if that's the case
then increasingly the locus of
interesting information is not going to
be
coming from your sales team but actually
coming from the product
and so to me it was who would who would
already feel that way and and could
could kind of agree and confirm that
they would want
the warehouse as the central brain
rather than
the crm as the central brain and and
that's
yeah that's where working with these
kinds of companies became
the right move but yeah not everyone was
on that
you know people are at different stages
of that journey obviously
interesting um and how did your early
experiences
um with these customers um
sort of uncover similar reactions that
um you've mentioned previously felt akin
to
folks sort of stepping into the devops
movement like you felt like
there was something really foundational
about
this model that was that was sort of a
sea
change with customers like talk to us
about
how that awareness you and you you
brought this up at the beginning of like
you know what
you know since we when we started our
first couple of users were not even
what you would traditionally call a data
team uh
involved a lot more of these business
operations teams so what led us to you
know where we are today and
i think there's a couple of things and
and i'll this this is how you can make
the final puzzle piece of my
my my professional life right because i
spent
the first half of my professional life
in developer tools
uh i worked on visual studio at
microsoft and love love love developer
tools so
so my mind was always attuned to that as
well and
what we saw was this so our first couple
users
you know started using census as a this
etl product and they actually even
started referring to it as a reverse etl
way back in yeah i think 2018 or 2019
and
is a kind of a it's a cute terminology
right because it's
people are so used to tools like five
tran that seamlessly bring your data
down into the warehouse and census was
seamlessly taking the data out of the
warehouse right
so they're like hey let's call that
reverse et and
the at first it's like augmenting
you know information that is in
their destination tools let's say like a
salesforce or a zendesk
but as they started depending on it more
and more
and and pushing more and more uh
attributes metrics
data objects etc into these tools
they the the value goes up right they
magnify
the the value of what was in their data
warehouse but they also
kind of took on more and more
responsibility
and this was the the that
the signal that was like you have to
manage this carefully
and you can't i think historically
uh when you think of that you know kind
of way people do app integration
people are somewhat haphazard about it
they just connect the thing to a thing
and then they just connect another thing
to another thing
and it's great hey like when someone
fills out our web form here like put
them into a mailchimp it's like
very easy very practical but you start
to lose like
what is the state of the world and is
the data correct and
how do we recover from errors and all
these things and our customers
because these were such crucial systems
to them right like the entire sales
process of figma was being powered by
census
literally the entirety of it and
this is becoming pretty critical so you
have to start
implicitly you have to start thinking
about your data
the way the way people who make products
think about products
i.e versioning it testing it
uh deploying it etc
and this was new
to them in fact it still is new to them
because they're not
engineers by by let's call it by
upbringing
and we've taught this for decades now
uh in the software engineering world
first when we were making
software on disks and then as we made
web software we developed
like newer processes and newer tools
right in the 20 in the 2000s and 2010s
of you know devops so whether that's all
the way from you know
uh you're versioning your code which is
like obvious and has been in the
industry for decades
to you know having a pager and and
managing like a pager rotation using
pages
and none of this really existed in the
data world
or in the business operations world and
so that
is the larger kind of mission for census
is to actually
not just help people connect the data
out and create this federation
of data out of your data warehouse but
help you do that
with confidence and the way to do that
is to kind of adopt
what i call devops practices and so i
think we're just going to adapt this to
data so it's like
folks are now calling that you know the
data ops ecosystem so
so just to make sure i understand so
what you're saying is that
this is essentially sort of the stakes
are much higher because
we're getting data in an automated
fashion from the data warehouse which
used to be the end of the etl now it
isn't anymore
we're getting it back into salesforce
we're using it to automatically
drive lead scoring lists or automated
outreach or salesperson outreach or
whatever
um and so because the stakes are so high
on this data that's being reimported
just
for example back to salesforce um you
know the customer has to trust the data
there has to be sort of
quality assurances there has to be slas
right um
you have to know if the data gets stale
um and so there's
sort of this whole other um end of the
orchestration
that's required in order for the
business teams to really
trust the the automated data that's
flowing back into their business systems
exactly and and that's i think
uh and you've you know you've been
watching the data world for a long time
too and
i think this we we catalyzed
i would say something that was like on
its way to happening but i think
census is i think a catalyst to
to investing in these uh this kind of
education
these kinds of tools and these kinds of
processes so
uh nowadays everyone's talking about how
you test your data right
it's you know one of the things that's
great about dbt for example is that you
can version your data models
but it's nice that you can also just
test them right there right
and that i think three years ago was
kind of neat but not necessary
uh because if your dashboard was wrong
what's the worst that happens
right you might get at the end of the
quarter like an angry meeting and then
you'll fix the dashboard with the
revenue like you fix it and then
you know okay we're okay but our
customers
i'll give you a great example uh one of
our earliest customers was
clear bit this is way way back uh
and they were uh their first integration
although they integrate with a lot of
different things
was to their email marketing tool
and before census they had lots of
different systems writing
data into the into the email marketing
tool and there are lots of duplicates
i'm talking like they would send an
email and sometimes seven the person
would get it seven times
and in the warehouse they could you know
the data analyst could
that use a census was able to kind of
deduplicate
build the correct you know kind of let's
call it master list of users with the
correct set of attributes
and basically overwrote the email
marketing tool completely from scratch
and seamlessly switched over to the
correct data set
and from that point forward the emails
were great however and this is the you
know what's the line from spider-man
like with great power comes you know
great responsibility
what was net new to her which had not
been the case for her ever before is if
you make a change to the data model now
the effect is like you're playing with
live ammo because the e this is
automated emails are going out
so if you screw up the data model just
accidentally
uh millions of people might get an email
within hours and so
that creates fear and to me this was
maybe the most it was i felt
really bad in a way for our user but
actually this was
a sign that we were doing something very
important because
empowerment like means you have more
responsibility which means
you have you you know you are going to
be more afraid to screw up right and you
have to have
then your tools have to help you and
give you the confidence and so census
started we started investing heavily at
that point in
validating your data before it goes out
and catching all sorts of failures
before they could happen
and i think that's a lot of you know
people at first will see census as like
a really easy way to push a metric from
your data warehouse into take your pick
right zendesk or salesforce or whatever
but the real value is it helps you do
that
while giving you the the confidence that
you're not going to screw up
and and that's that's what you realize
after a little bit of using it
and and that also means you're working
on something important right because i i
ultimately think products are about
empowering people and you know you've
empowered people when they're more
afraid
yeah if you realize your your tool has
that much leverage
and power sort of where it work where
it's sitting in the in the value chain
um that's definitely indicative of
something something good
yeah well um i think we've kind of
danced around it but i just wanted to to
give you a chance to sound off on
on your views on operational analytics i
mean we've basically sort of talked all
around this concept
but yeah um that's a term that you've
preferred to use
i know in the past and it seems like
you know if there's a banner that sort
of goes over this whole conversation
that we've had so far it's really
the fact that businesses need to start
to think about um
data in terms of you know the
operational power it can give to their
business versus just sort of
being a function that stops at a bi tool
in a dashboard somewhere
yeah yeah i think it's a really nice
name
uh because we work with analysts we work
with analytics teams we work with data
teams
and the whole point of census if you
haven't already bought into it is
your everything that you do in a
dashboard
everything all the data modeling you do
all that interesting insight you
generate whether that's through
ml data science you name it would be
more
powerful if it was pushed into systems
where people are taking action i.e
operationalized it was put into the way
the business is run
rather than the way the business is
informed right which is what a dashboard
does and
don't get me wrong like bi was a
significant step forward in the last
20 years of like well now a lot of
companies have great data
when they make strategic decisions but
to me that was that's not really data
driven right that's not data powered
that's just informed by data which is
great
but the census difference is
operationalize that
those analytics like those those the
output of your data team
rather than even just like the raw data
so so that's why we use this term
operational analytics
even though it's very long uh i guess we
should do a we should probably get a
18 in there somewhere um but
i think it really summarizes
the shift and the interesting thing is
it's not just that you should think
about
how to use your data like the fact that
you should
push it out to more than a dashboard
more than a bi tool which is
you know the first hump right it's like
if we can help you realize that there's
more you can do with your analytics
that's great
and then like i said that becomes a
catalyst for
investing in your data team and in the
core
right which i think is actually the the
the real job to be done of data teams is
building a foundation so that the entire
company can depend
on the data organization and that's new
as a bi team you are like you said
you're a sync right you're you're the
final stage
not just as a piece of software in the
data warehouse in the bi tool but
but actually as a team as well you're
like a leaf node
and with census and kind of this broader
operational analytics
approach you're no longer right now you
have dependence
at a software level and so you have to
reorganize
your team and you also have to kind of
reorganize your
logic your data well
let's let's drill into that a little bit
more because um
i know there are some significant
challenges um
in philosophy and values and you know
just mentality
um if if a data team were to sort of
you know expand some of their purview um
and start to be responsible for
this kind of data that flows back into
business systems like
like how do you think the culture the
mentality of a team has to change
how should they think of themselves um
sort of in this new era what
what does this mean for a data team yeah
i think this is a deep
deep vein and there's a lot and i think
we're in the midst of like a really fun
shift and transformation here anyway and
so i've got
very uh uh strong opinions uh that
will probably not all pan out to be true
but but i think
uh they're worth putting into the world
so i think you have to make
not only you have to make two kinds of
shifts as you
expand the the the footprint of your
of your data team the first is actually
technical which is you can't if all you
build is reports
i think there's there's a tendency to
just take data that's just
you know hey you'll you'll drop some
data into warehouse you'll you'll run
like a report and like generate the
visual
and we know right like we already know
that if you're gonna have to build one
report you can just do that if you're
gonna build 10
maybe you build one tiny abstraction if
you're gonna build a hundred or a
thousand
obviously you have to build some
reusable models
and that's the you know that's the first
shift and i think we're still at the
beginning of that if you really look
broadly at the
at the whole world i think the the
the nerds have already adopted kind of
best practices around here around like
dbt has really exploded as a great tool
for creating central models that you can
version
but it really it the very infancy of
that and
i think there's gonna be a lot of onus
on the technical side on the logical
like code side of
what should those models look like such
that they can be reused
by reports but also reused by
uh these destination sas applications
and if i were to reframe to you what
census was trying to accomplish and
still is always trying to accomplish is
turn your data warehouse and that you
own into the you know the central brain
and the central data
store for you and your company and make
every third-party sas app like a cache
on that data so you got to come up with
the right data models for that and we
have a lot of patterns that we kind of
help customers build here so that they
can
do this well so so so that's
you know kind of one transformation it's
almost like a pure technical level
the technical side yeah and then there's
the organizational side and i think
there
there is changes within and changes
outside of your data team so
i think within we're already starting to
see this but you have to
kind of you know a lot of people might
say what
the data team is just the data science
team and i think that's too small-minded
right so
you really have at least three types of
people or three layers within your data
organization
you've got the core data engineering
team which i think still will always
exist
potentially building like owning the
low-level infrastructure you know
setting up the snowflake building
certain kinds of pipelines i think over
time they're gonna they're gonna be a
lot of
there's gonna be a lot more purchasing
rather than building in that environment
but
you know there is always going to be
some amount of software to be built
then you have this analytics engineering
layer of a team right that is
focused on sql focus on the data models
but is about building reusable things
and then you've got what i'll call the
you know the tail of it which is the
data science and
and analysts who are finding insights
using that data doing interesting things
and that's
you know i think not every company has
decided that the data team is all of
this combined
because and the reason i know this is i
one of those people at least one set of
those people
are for sure engineers and it is unusual
for an engineer to report to a finance
team
but most bi teams report to a finance
team so
so i think the the there's like within
organizational change right so you
should create one leader
around those all of those pieces even if
the data analysts are going to be
loaned out to uh to business teams
right which is totally reasonable but i
think you should have one center of
excellence for this
and then you uh from outside as the ceo
you kind of want to think about where
does this sit so that it can provide
maximal value to the business and
the whole point of operational analytics
is that you don't just serve
the finance team and the wall street
side of with with dashboards and revenue
reports
you serve the sales team the support
team the finance team the product team
the you know the marketing team there's
so many teams that you serve
through these centralized data models so
you actually have to
reformat you know where the comp the
organization sits and
who it formerly has a stakeholders and
in my mind it should be
i actually think it should be a
foundational piece of the company i
actually think
the data team should be like a platform
team for the whole company
i don't know anyone who does that yet
just to be clear
and i think for that to happen a you're
going to need
something that is akin to a chief data
officer or at least something that
reports pretty closely to the cto almost
almost certainly
and you're gonna need to shift from
it thinking which is i think where data
has historically been
which is reactive to requests from
various stakeholders
towards product thinking and that's i
think a really big shift
yeah for sure i mean it seems like that
that could be a conversation
um you know it thinking versus product
thinking um as
as an overlay on a data team i think
that's a
that's a new concept that um could
definitely be explored
in a much deeper conversation because i
think there's a lot there
yeah i mean the more
i think most people who listen who have
dealt with
are in data or have been around data i
mean it's very classic to get
questions you know like hey can you fix
this report can you build me a report
it's probably the most common thing can
you answer this question for me
and we talk a lot about how do we make
that self-service which
helps a little bit but of course that
also moves the burden of education to
the
to to the edge nodes um
but i think when i say product thinking
i i actually mean that you don't just
acquiesce to every request you actually
take that all in and um
and decide on a whether that's a weekly
every other week every month doesn't
matter you create a cadence of shipping
and you you know you you take all that
feedback in as the same way that a
product
like the census team gets customer
requests 24 7
right and the law of software is you
cannot ship everything
a because you don't have bandwidth b
because it doesn't always make sense
right and you want a great product
experience
and so the data team has to kind of take
that on
and i actually think product managers
should exist in every data organization
for example uh
whose job it is is to manage the product
that is the data so
so communicating with stakeholders
reducing it down to what we're going to
ship
and and and creating a cadence around
that and
and and and then sharing that with the
whole company uh
and yeah it's like the switch from it's
like it's like the switch from the
project manager um which basically like
manages a project
plan yeah to a product manager
which essentially like sort of manages a
product roadmap
and so it's a much more strategic way of
thinking about
your data teams deliverables against
project management
or sorry product management guidelines
versus just the the project management
which is sort of typical in the i.t
based world as you mentioned yeah i
think that's really spot-on right like
you know when you're doing a hey we
gotta roll out new uh
new new access points for the wi-fi
right like that's very much a project
but here it's you're right it's a road
map of what's gonna change
in the in the in in the tools and then
the products
and by the way it's not just that right
i think a really good rule of thumb for
people
is to go back to our earlier
conversation about
devops and data ops is we devise those
processes
for a reason because they are really
well optimized
for shipping software shipping product
at high velocity with high confidence
so you want to have
versioning of your code why so that you
can
rewind right so that you can collaborate
like so that you can kind of branch
right these are all the reasons you we
version our code and
that applies to high velocity data
shipping as well
right you want to be able to have
staging environments so that
you can test stuff out as you go out to
production
right you want to do that with data as
well uh
you want to be able to have automated
testing
before data or code is deployed right
and again there are certain tools
emerging to do that
um and then you want to deploy right the
same way you
go to production in a software
application and census is actually
that's a great way to think about census
census
is a deployment tool right because it
deploys your data
into all of the third-party systems that
depend on it
and so we're there to kind of have your
back right and and
prevent you from deploying bad data
which would be
disastrous and i i think all of this is
you know just brand new processes that
people are
putting in place yeah so you so as you
mentioned before
you would like to your vision of the
world is to see
the the data warehouse be the central
brain of the organization and all of the
other third-party
systems essentially have caches of that
data is that a
is that the best way you can think about
explaining your biggest vision
for for this area
i think the
that's a it's a good i think we landed
on a really good nerdy definition of it
so i like it uh but
yeah i think this the data warehouse is
one of the greatest pieces of technology
i think that's happened in the last you
know let's say five
five to ten years infinite scale of
storage and compute
and it's just a much better platform for
storing
you know your customer data and your
core you know kind of data that you care
about as a company
i think it's important for companies to
own their data
i think you should think about that as
something that you manage
and and build out as a company i think
it's your core
value right and i think you should be
able to use
any sas product to drive any business
operation
some of our customers have 300 sas
applications that they use
so it's not just that i want those
applications to be a cache it's actually
that i just want to empower companies
to be able to build any operation any
automation using any sas
product and the way to do that is to
have a product like census there to
federate that data out for you
and then you know for me the the
ultimately products are about people
and about making them like i said the
best versions of themselves
and so the the goal
if we can turn data practitioners into
some of the most powerful people in a
company some of the most leveraged
people in a company
i will consider like you know that that
a job well done and we're nowhere near
that today
yeah got it um well
i just you know as we wrap up i i wanted
to ask you
um what are your insights on this
broader space like what are you excited
about
sort of happening in the near future um
in this space
and and also sort of in relation to that
um what are some of the key insights
that you've picked up as you as you've
come this
this far thus far and been involved in
sort of the curation of this
this new category of tooling yeah
so i think there's a lot that's exciting
right um
and i'll give you one example
which is to me i'm excited by anything
that it
moves the the kind of quality and
capabilities of the core
which is let's call it the warehouse and
database technology itself
so the more you use census
the more you operationalize your
analytics
the the more you realize
that you've you know you're magnifying
the value of your data it's great
but bit by bit you will just you will
realize that there are scenarios in
which you want lower and lower latency
and to me this is a really exciting kind
of development
in the data warehouse and let's call it
the the grand merger of data lakes data
warehouses and streaming and all these
various pieces
that are coming together basically and
especially incremental materialized
views are kind of like my favorite thing
right now
that are getting our customers and
people closer to be able to
to deliver data
at lower lazy like fresh data correct
data at lower latency
and the more you can do that the more
you can turn on
scenarios that are powering the business
so
take take take a classic thing that a
lot of our customers are doing companies
like notion and figma are doing this
every day in census
they they have scoring systems that that
run through census right so the
sql scoring systems that
determine who is the most active users
uh how large of a team they are all
these kinds of
signals that they aggregate into a score
that says
you are worthy we should we should talk
to you for a sales conversation
by the way some of our customers use
that in a different way which is i want
to
provide you different service on the
support side so they'll sync that data
with a support tool
to be able to prioritize tickets it's a
really cool kind of way of using
the same the same piece of information
so
so you have this scoring system and then
you push that you create leads right in
your crm and then that generates work
and a call
well sometimes the
the value of making that phone call
within 24 hours versus within one hour
versus within 15 minutes could be real
and so the more
our data technology can get us to
running the entirety of the data
pipeline including kind of the
the transformation layer the the
ingestion layer
and the testing layer all that in such a
way that it can
get you the answer and push it out in
less time is is super empowering
and so i think that's that's probably
one of my favorite areas so
you know companies like materialize i
think are really really cool for
getting people closer and closer to that
that world view of like hey
you just build models they're
incrementally materialized it happens
faster and faster
someday you know we'll get to sub second
but like we're not there today but like
we'll get there and i think that's
really really exciting yeah well we
haven't even talked about how
um you know census might play in in the
streaming data world but
obviously um i think that could be very
interesting
going forward uh streaming obviously has
to
live up to its end of the bargain and
you know it's
sort of become something that the world
can really
um operationalize and take hold of
without building
infinitely complex systems um such as
streaming
systems so sometimes are totally totally
well i'll give you
actually i'll give you yeah we can't get
into that fully but i'll give you you
asked for like what's an insight what's
something i've seen and
you know one of the interesting
pitfalls or mistakes i've seen people do
is even way outside of core engineering
people are really addicted to the idea
of events and activity streams so
marketers love that too
um and what i found is
people over index on the value
like the cool things you get from event
processing
uh and not enough on the downsides so
what i mean by that is
it's absolutely necessary at high scale
you know kind of
in high scale systems so on the
engineering side of course you're gonna
need
at some point something like a stream
processing system like a kafka or
whatever
to manage messaging at scale and event
processing at scale
but believe it or not you see the same
behavior without the same words
on sales and marketing teams where they
say hey every time someone hits the
website i just want the event
you know like they came to the website
or they swiped a credit card or they did
a thing
and one of the things i try to teach
because
you can sync events you can sync state
but census really i i'm constantly
trying to push people to realize that
with the right tooling which you know
we've built
syncing state is actually in many cases
better for you
than syncing the events and i have found
that business teams
because they don't have they're not
versed in the you know kind of what's
called the computer science
of like event-based thinking versus
state-based thinking
it's it's actually a lesson that takes
them a while to learn
and the reason is like at first it seems
great hey every time
you know user added to org i just want
the event user added to org
but if you don't know how to aggregate
the data in your marketing tool to
realize that people get deleted from
orgs
and that you actually have to maintain
that logic at every
layer of the system versus putting that
in your
warehouse putting that in the central
brain and having a tool like census just
sync the
ultimate value so hey there are now 12
users according to you know
the aggregation map that we have and
census will make that true everywhere
we'll say it's 12
everywhere don't worry about it and that
is the correctness that you get from
that is so much
more valuable in my opinion than the
immediacy you get from
user got added right and and this is
something that people don't really see
yeah so that's that's that's i'll give
you that that's a kind of insight that
i've seen people
struggle with and they don't know why
because they it's somewhat difficult
it's like kind of distributed systems
kind of thinking you have to have
yeah that's a very interesting insight
and that makes perfect sense
well boris um it's been great to have
you you know share with us today thanks
for
for taking time to share all your
learnings and experiences in the data
ecosystem
i'm curious how can folks get a hold of
you if they um
want to be in touch yeah yeah i'd love
to talk about this with anyone so
uh i'll give them my email it's like
boris at getcensus.com
uh and i'm sure we'll put that in the
show notes somewhere
and people feel free to gold email me
i'd love to talk about these things
anytime
uh you can find me on twitter it's my
full name boris chabess
and uh you know you can go to
getcensus.com if you want to just reach
out to anyone else on our team
and you're going to find people on our
team and hang out in all the data
communities
but yeah that's just love talking about
someone
excellent thanks for having me well i'm
sure i'm sure people will um take you up
on that and
and chase you down so uh borah shabazz
thank you for joining us
thank you and
to the rest of our listeners thanks as
well for tuning in uh we'll have another
episode next week
may 27th i'll be talking with julian
ledem
the co-founder and cto of datakin on the
new
open lineage project that datakin has
created so
don't miss that as i think that'll be a
great chat as well
um don't forget to subscribe to the
youtube channel and hit the bell icon so
that you get notifications
and thanks again for joining